hey this is really interesting New
Hampshire Republican Senate candidate
Don balduck last month said the election
was stolen by Joe Biden and Trump won
yesterday on Fox News balduck was
confronted with his own comments and he
denounced them and he said you know what
I did my research Biden won
take a look at this
basically against Morse the more
establishment Republican candidate
because they were basically saying that
you're so extreme that they think that
you're more beatable and one of the
things that Maggie Hassan the Senate
incumbent will say is that you are an
election denier that you deny that
President Biden won the 2020 election
and there's this from August 14th when
you had a debate watch here
I signed a letter with 120 other
generals and Admirals saying that Trump
won the election and damn it I stand by
myself wow do you stand by that today
no
so you know we uh we we uh you know live
and learn right
um and I've done a lot of research on
this and I've spent the past couple of
weeks talking to Granite Staters all
over the state uh from uh you know every
party and I have come to the conclusion
and I want to be definitive on this the
election was not stolen was there fraud
yes is that a concern of granite Staters
all over the state yes there is is there
a responsibility for public servants and
elected positions to ensure that our
citizens have faith in their voting
system yes but elections have
consequences and unfortunately
President Biden is the legitimate
president of this country and he is
ruining it along with Maggie Hassan so
listen
is it good that balduck is willing to
say this well yeah it's good because
some people on Fox News might hear it
does this represent his real and true
personal belief
I have no idea because the real
interpretation of what balduck is doing
here is he realized that with New
Hampshire voters insisting that the
election was stolen and Trump actually
won isn't helping him that's
fundamentally what this is about
and so it's about political expediency
my guess is balduck never believed that
Trump actually won I think he was saying
it because he thought it would help him
and then when it became clear it wasn't
helping him he stopped saying it but
it's still nice for Fox News viewers to
hear that